Oh là… le ciel se couvre !
Et pourquoi les nuages passent-ils du blanc au gris ?
Le soleil émet de la lumière blanche.
Il s’agit en fait d’une combinaison
de plusieurs ondes électromagnétiques
qui correspondent aux couleurs de l’arc-en-ciel.
Il y a aussi des ondes électromagnétiques
auxquelles nos yeux ne sont pas sensibles.
En théorie, la lumière se déplace en ligne droite.
Quand elle pénètre dans l’atmosphère terrestre,
elle rencontre des obstacles :
les molécules qui composent l’air
et quand il y a des nuages comme aujourd’hui,
la vapeur d’eau, les gouttelettes et les cristaux
de glace qui forment ces nébulosités.
Ces obstacles absorbent et dévient la lumière
en la diffusant dans toutes les directions.
Voilà pourquoi les nuages nous apparaissent
blancs, comme la lumière émise par le soleil.
Enfin, tant que le nuage n’est pas trop épais.
Les cumulonimbus,
ces nuages qui se forment quand il y a de l’orage,
peuvent s’étirer sur quinzaine de kilomètres de hauteur.
Dans ces conditions, la lumière est quasiment
entièrement absorbée par la tête du nuage.
La base n’est plus éclairée.
Elle ne diffuse plus ou très peu de lumière.
Le nuage est gris, parfois presque noir.
Oh là ! J’ai la tête dans les nuages,
un peu comme dans une « capsule de déconfiné»
Si vous avez aimé cette capsule,
n’hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
Vous pouvez également voir ou revoir celles des jours précédents, il vous suffit de cliquer sur la gauche.
J’en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Pour être sûr de n’en louper aucune,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
A demain et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.